hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe
I'm your host Sean Carroll and this is
the Q&A video associated with idea
number 11 which was renormalization this
of course was in a video that gave me an
excuse to talk about effective field
theories the Whittle Sounion approach to
renormalization which says you tell me
some ultraviolet cut off some energy
scale above which I don't pretend to
know what is happening and that I can
give you a description of the infrared
physics so I can give you a description
of what's happening at low energies to
particles with masses and momenta below
that cut off without knowing anything
about what's going on in the very very
short distances the very very high
energies so we got some pretty good
questions here so I think I'm just gonna
do a straightforward kind of Q&A thing
try to address some of these questions
and you know I'm gonna rephrase them
into my own terms so one question I'm
letting make sure how to phrase a
question but it basically has to do with
the status of virtual particles our
virtual particles real things do they
really exist are they really popping in
and out of existence a lot of times a
few times I think this is phrased in the
context of black holes and Hawking
radiation which we're not talking about
yet we'll get there eventually there
will be black holes in the future but
right now we're just in flat space-time
and ordinary quantum field theory so
let's stay there for this discussion
our virtual particles real well kind of
depends on what you mean by real I mean
think about this idea that we had where
two particles come in there's a blob of
stuff and then two particles go out in
fact let's make this two electrons
coming in okay no let's make an electron
and positron coming in so the electron
this goes in that way and out that way
because a positron can be thought of as
an electron going backward in time an
electron and positron come out I think I
did emphasize this already but you know
the arrows here are not directions of
travel this is not the momentum of the
particle this is the direction of the
electron Mis which travels in one
direction for an electron moving one way
and travels opposite for the positron
moving the same way and we said look
this is a process
this is what you want to know the answer
to what is the probability that this
happens and we write it as a sum of
different things happening right so one
possibility is there's a photon
interchange like this and I'll draw the
arrows just this once but there are
other possibilities so here's a
possibility that the electrons go in
turn into photons and then come out so
here's electron this going this way and
here it is going this way and there's
many many other contributions there's an
infinite number of contributions so the
point of this is we start with some
configuration of quantum fields that
look particle like so there's a
wavefunction for the quantum fields and
it's localized in two different
positions one with an electron field
vibrating the other with a positron
field vibrating they come in nearby they
overlap all sorts of different fields
vibrate like the photon field this is
the electromagnetic field gamma the
photon that is contributing to this
interaction and then they go their own
way they separate out once again so the
statement that we make is that this
process can be calculated by thinking of
these Viman diagrams with virtual
particles inside and then summing over
all the contributions we get from all
the virtual particles so the question is
will all the virtual particles real well
the process is real and we have a way of
calculating that process in some sense
what's real are the quantum fields in
fact in some sense what is real is the
wave function of the universe and the
wave function of the universe describes
all these quantum fields but it is the
thing that is real and some very big
sets so you have to have a more
sophisticated notion of what you mean by
real one attitude or one thing to notice
is if this process is a sum over all of
these Feynman diagrams then no one of
these Fineman diagrams is the single
real thing right
these Fineman diagrams are individual
contributions to the real thing so in
some sense no these virtual particles
are not real they are part of a story
that we tell but the story gives us the
right answer and the story you know
you tell a story in physics and say well
this is what the story we're telling has
involved it leads to this conclusion
there's a sense in which that's real
right there's essential which as long as
it gives us the right answer it's real
so in other words what I'm saying here
is kind of don't get hung up on the idea
of whether or not the virtual particles
are real or not the process is real the
quantum fields that are in the wave
function of the universe are real the
virtual particles are a way of telling
us what happens to them they're not fake
they're not a mistake it's not an
illusion it's not like there's something
that's actually happening the virtual
particles are a wrong way of talking
about it but they are a way of talking
about it this does become a little bit
more that there's a closely related
question which is what about when you
don't have a scattering process what
about when you have some process that is
simply static like let's say we have a
hydrogen atom okay that is just sitting
there so hydrogen atom we're able to say
okay here's a proton P plus and there's
an electron let me see if I can do this
correctly yeah the electron we can think
of as a wave function that is spread out
right and that's a cloud of electron II
- and that's how we discuss it in
nonrelativistic quantum mechanics okay
and in quantum field theory we would say
well there are fields and they give rise
in the right limit in the right sort of
approximation to part of the wave
function describing a single proton part
of the wave function describing a single
electron and they're interacting so
there is a fine 'men diagram way of
talking about this and that is you can
say that this hydrogen atom can be
thought of in you know in time it's not
changing right it's just sitting there
but here is an electron with its
electron is flowing in this direction
here is a proton with its proton this
floating flowing in that direction and
what's happening is that the electron
and the proton are exchanging photons
okay
virtual particles photons time is
running this way but in some sense there
are little virtual particle photons
gamma
being changed back and forth between the
electron and the proton this is a way
not the only way not necessarily the
best way but a way of thinking about how
to calculate the properties of the
electron in the hydrogen atom but the
important thing to notice here is of
course so there is in that hydrogen even
though I didn't draw it there is an
electromagnetic field as well as an
electron and a positron but nothing is
changing over time the wave function
which you can actually solve for just a
nonrelativistic quantum mechanics you
don't need quantum field theory or
climate diagrams to do it but you could
use them the wave function is static it
is constant over time the story we tell
about the electron in the positron in
the Fineman diagram language is a sum of
many many things every one of those
things is not constant in time right
here is a diagram for little photons
going back and forth and in the same
time period you may have another diagram
with one photon another with two and
three and many other diagrams with criss
cross and so forth so we sum up all
these dynamical processes in time
represented by individual Kleinman
diagrams to get us an answer which is
time independent which is just sitting
there and static so it is more real to
talk about what the wave function of the
electron the photon and the proton are
doing then to talk about the individual
Fineman diagrams of which they're made
so you can tell a story of the electron
bound to the proton as a story of
virtual photons popping in out of
existence traveling back and forth
between the electron and the proton and
binding the electron causing a force as
I did in the renormalization video you
can even use that story to sort of
justify how we talk about
renormalization right the cloud of
virtual particles around the electron
kind of fades away as you get further
away there's a shielding effect that
makes the net charge of the electron
look a little bit less if you're far
away from it than if you're nearby these
are all stories you can tell but they're
stories that remember are describing a
static thing okay so there are not
Trulli dynamical virtual particles
popping in and out of existence in this
situation there's not anything bubbling
beneath the surface if you were to
observe it if you were to take something
I don't know really really good
microscope okay and take this hydrogen
atom and say where is the electron well
then you're doing something different
you're disturbing the system because
you're measuring it right in the bring
the language we talked about before
you're interacting with it
you're becoming entangled with it so
you're changing its wavefunction so
you'd never see this electron wave
function spread out this goes back to
the discussion we had about quantum
mechanics quantum field theory is just
part of quantum mechanics and it's the
same discussion there is something that
is happening when we're not looking at
it which is the electron has a static
wavefunction nothing is changing over
time and something you would see were
you to look at it so if you were to look
for the electron you would see it in
some location if you were to reset the
electron back to its lowest energy state
to look again you would see it at some
different location likewise if you could
somehow measure the photon or the
electromagnetic field you would see
values for that and every time you
looked you would see it a little bit
different because you're sampling in
different ways from some probability
distribution okay so if you look over
and over again you get a picture over
time as if the electron is jiggling
around but that's not what's happening
when you're not looking at it when
you're not looking at it everything is
perfectly static so this is a situation
where the story we tell of an L
particles popping in and out of
existence is misleading there is nothing
that is different from one moment of
time to another moment of time there's
no no sense in which you can say at one
moment of time there are three virtual
photons and another moment there are
four virtual photons that is a
nonsensical statement the wavefunction
of all three of these things the proton
the electron and the photon they're
static they're the same at every moment
in time so I hope that helps a little
bit and trying to figure out how we
should talk about these particles you
know by the way this goes into the next
thing we'll talk about you can even tell
the story of Fineman diagrams for a
single particle remember I drew the
picture of an electron with virtual
particles pumping in and out
of space around it so we can talk about
the propagator for a single particle the
propagator is a way of talking about
just a single particle all by itself
moving through space okay so here's an
electron moving through space there it
is very simple timing diagram right but
in some sense this is equal to a whole
bunch of different things it's equal to
the electron really did just go all by
itself plus the electron is going all by
itself but it emitted a photon and then
it reabsorbed the photon that's
something that could happen
plus the electrons going all by itself
and it emitted a photon and it emitted
another photon and they cross each other
plus the electrons going all by itself
and then it emits a photon and then the
photon turns into an electron-positron
pair and then they annihilate and then
they get reabsorbed by the photon plus
its loops by the electron plus etc so
this is a Fineman diagram way of talking
about just a single particle I mean you
know time is running left to right but
the electron doesn't even have to be
moving right the electron could just be
literally sitting there and we would
describe it as an infinite sum of
Fineman diagrams so to calculate what's
going on the virtual particles are very
useful but the true thing that is going
on is they're a field that is vibrating
and all the other fields that interacts
with vibrate along with it that's what's
really happening okay and the vibrations
might be static and in other words the
vibrations might be a certain shape I
don't remember I say vibrate I don't
necessarily mean literally changing in
time sorry about that I mean there is a
shape a profile to the wave function
that may or may not be changing in time
which brings us to the next question
which I think is a little bit harder for
me to answer which is how do fields
interact I think that this is one of
those questions that arises because we
have sort of a built-in intuitive idea
for what we mean by things interacting
with each other and an idea doesn't
quite apply to field or something like
this when people say how do the fields
interact you know what kind of answer
could you possibly be hoping
to get so if you if you say well the
earth interacts with the Sun
gravitationally what do you mean is you
have the earth and the Sun and there's a
gravitational field in between and you
know both the earth and the Sun create
and respond to the gravitational field
and there you go so if you say well how
do fields interact themselves I'm
tempted to say you know that's what they
do
remember what's the way that we're
describing things again the most
fundamental description would just be
the wave function of the universe but
the wave function the universe assigns
different amplitudes two fields doing
different things so at every point in
space there's a bunch of fields okay at
every point in space you know in some
way in some ways you can you can think
about it like this so here is space
space and at every point there are
multiple fields that exist so what you
might want to do is draw them as a
series of different copies of space and
they looks like they're on top of each
other but I separated them out just so I
could draw them but really it's exactly
the same copy of space and here you have
the electron field let's call it E - of
X here you have the photon field gamma
of X here you have the proton field it
could be the positron field every single
field exists in fact let's do that this
is P plus of X let's put the positron
here
positron field there's also the
gravitational field etc this is e + of X
so the point is I've drawn four
different copies of space but they're
the same space there's same location the
same representation of the
three-dimensional space in which we
lived and the rules of the game given by
the locality of the dynamics of the
fields are that these fields can
interact in the sense that the value of
the field or the derivatives of the
field at one point in space can interact
and be influenced by and influence the
values of the other fields at the same
point so that is encompassed in what we
talked about in the
and I guess the second last video on
interactions in the Lagrangian for the
field so you have an action s which is
an integral over time DT of L that's the
Lagrangian and then you have the
Lagrangian L is written as an integral
over space so that's d3 acts the three
dimensions of space of a Lagrange
density in the Lagrangian settees itself
a function of all these fields so e
minus of X gamma of X and T I'm I'm
assuming that time is in there as well
as space P plus proton field e plus the
positron field and so on
know why that keeps happening okay but
the point is that the Lagrangian
Lagrange density is going to look like a
product a sum of products of fields
where the fields are evaluated at the
same point of space-time so there might
be something that says e minus e sorry
let me be very specific is the whole
point
II - of X y plus of X gamma of X and
real particle physicists in the audience
know that I'm hiding a lot of details
here there are indices there's spinners
and vectors and the whole bit
just subsuming all that but the point is
this kind of term in the interaction
lagrangian for the fields says that an
electron and a positron can interact
with the photon and this leads to a
Fineman diagram that looks like this
II - y + gamma in different kinds of
terms of the lagrangian give rise to
different Fineman diagrams but the
crucial thing is they're all evaluated
at the same point in space you never
have a minus of x times e + of y where x
and y are different from each other okay
that's the notion of locality and this
the reason why we iterating all this
I've said it all before
is because this term in the interaction
Lagrangian tells us the interaction of
the fields this tells us how the fields
influence each other this says that if I
have an electron field vibrating and a
photon field vibrating that can
influence the vibration of the positron
field and vice versa all the different
combinations that you might have and if
you want to say well how I think
interacting like what does it mean that
they're interacting it that's all it
means I don't know what else to say
that's what fields do fields affect each
other in accordance with this kind of
set up equations of motion remember the
whole point of the action in the action
formulation of mechanics or the
Lagrangian or whatever is from all these
different expressions you can derive the
full equations of motion classically or
you could write the full Schrodinger
equation quantum mechanically so you can
tell us how the fields evolved so that
that's the point of quantum field theory
there's no deeper level there's no
answer to the question while the fields
interact by exchanging handshakes or
baseballs or something like that or
shocking each other or I don't even know
what it would be the fields by their
very existence by their behavior at
different locations in space affect what
other fields are doing that is
manifested in the equations of motion or
in the Lagrangian or in the Schrodinger
equation the Hamiltonian whichever
language you want to use but that is
what is happening there's no sort of
deeper answer to the question how are
the fields interacting with each other
but I don't know I don't know if that
was a satisfying answer to that
particular question but that is the best
I can do okay oh yeah the
renormalization group this is the next
question this is something I mentioned
but I think it's not that I'm answering
your question about it it's just I'm
gonna say the same thing that I tried to
say before I'm going to say it again in
slightly different language hopefully it
will be a little bit more clear what is
going on here the point is that Wilson
Ken Wilson tells us to put a cutoff on
our final diagrams so we have a Fineman
diagram let's say that just it looks
like a generic box like this
and we have certain mount of energy is
going in and then we have what I called
ebar which is certain route of energy
that is going around the loop so ebar is
not specified just by the boundary
conditions of what the energy coming in
here he 1 e 2 e 3 I forget how you label
them before before probably the other
way around doesn't matter there's an
unspecified amount of energy that goes
through the loop so therefore you sum
over all the possible values of E bar
and what wilson says is you sum only up
to some value of the energy right it
can't go above some energy and that's
the ultraviolet cutoff the worry is when
you do that that who says what the
cutoff is supposed to be like if I did a
different cutoff then wouldn't I get a
different answer because the let me see
if I can do this move this around there
we go so the process that we're looking
at represented by this diagram as a
whole is the sum over all values of e
bar of the individual diagrams for this
so shortly if we add up the
contributions of every different value
of e bar the energy running through the
loop if I change the range over which I
do that sum then I should get a
different sir right I'm including some
extra stuff or I'm not and the point of
the renormalization group was well what
we can do is we have coupling constants
like let's say the fine structure
constants fine structure constant alpha
okay alpha equals 137 we usually say
what Wilson reveals to us and actually
this is built on work that was done
earlier by Murray gell-mann Francis Lowe
and other people you should think of the
fine structure constant not as a
constant but as something that depends
on your ultraviolet cutoff and I forget
what I called it e star this is what I
want to call it in this video anyway
this is the cutoff the point of what
Wilson says is and different again
different people have said different
versions of this but the point is
yes if I change my cutoff then I'm
adding a different set of Lyman diagrams
together but in every diagram in each
diagram and all these vertices I have a
factor that is related to the coupling
constant in particular in QED quantum
electrodynamics every vertex comes with
the square root of alpha in it the
charge of the electron in another way of
thinking about it so what I can do is
change the cutoff and also change all my
coupling constants to compensate that's
what this notation means alpha as a
function of E store the cutoff I can get
the same answer at the end of the day
the same answer for this question what
is the probability that electron and a
positron scatter off each other no
matter what my cutoff is by choosing the
value of the fine-structure constant the
renormalized value the fine-structure
constant appropriately and the miracle
so you of course you can do that once
right for one process for an electron
and a positron coming in then bouncing
off of each other I could always just by
hand choose a value of alpha so again
whatever answer I want as a function of
the cutoff but the nice thing is you
only do it once once you have that
coupling constant as a function of
energy the same function the same alpha
as a function of the cutoff energy works
for any process not just an electron
scattering off a positron but an
electron scattering off of another
electron or an electron positron
annihilating into two photons or too
[ __ ] up two photons creating an
electron a positron or two electrons and
do process all the different processes
you can imagine can be described by the
same renormalized cutoff that is the
miracle of effective field theory and
this is called the renormalization group
the realization group is simply how the
different coupling constants chains as
you change the coupling constant for
those of you know those of you to know
what a group is a group in mathematics
is sort of a set of things you can add
together or multiply together and there
is a inverse and there's a whole list
you know there's different sets of
restrictions for what a group is your
normalization group is not really group
at all but the name
was given to it and it's stuck the
renormalization group is how you change
your coupling constants as you change
your cutoff so that your infrared
low-energy processes get the same answer
and so I think that answering the
questions as well as I could I mean the
questions were basically how in the
world can this work this is how it works
I think I tried to say this in the
previous video but I'm not sure I did a
good job so that is my that is my
attempt of doing a better job okay here
is something that wasn't quite a
question but it was kind of implied by a
question effective field theory EFT I
said that an effective field theory is a
way of talking about what happens at low
energies given a certain cutoff you say
I admit I don't know what happens if
arbitrarily low energies by having a
theory for my low energy stuff that is
effective that is good enough okay what
I didn't say but is true I mean I don't
remember saying it anyway is it
effective field theories can what's the
best way to say this let's just dive in
can have different ontologies remember I
talked about I have talked about in the
past I'm sorry I've been talking so much
recently between the podcast and the
videos and so forth but I forget what
I've said and what I haven't I don't
think I did say this there's something
called emergence the emergence of a
description of physical reality at a
higher level so you have a box of gas is
a very typical thing to have describing
by the language of emergence we know
that inside the box of gas there are
atoms there are molecules they're
bumping into each other so we can
describe what's going on by in principle
listing every position and every
momentum and every orientation of every
atom and also the identity of every atom
is that oxygen or is it a carbon dioxide
molecule or whatever but there's another
way of talking about what's going on
inside the box the emergent way of
talking about is a fluid right it has a
certain density at every point in space
a certain pressure or certain
temperature a certain that velocity all
these different things and what you say
is that I can describe the gas using the
fluid within a certain domain of
Lidda T or a certain diminutive
applicability I can't do it if there's
only one atom in the box and it does not
have a fluid description but there are a
lot of atoms in the box their Avogadro's
number or more then I can describe it
using using this fluid description and
the interesting thing about that is that
the fluid description is perfectly good
it gives the same predictions within its
domain of applicability as the atom and
molecule description does it's not as
comprehensive there are circumstances
where there's small numbers of atoms or
molecules where it doesn't work but when
it works it works just as well up to
some level of approximation so it's kind
of an effective field theory right like
I didn't derive it using fiving diagrams
for anything like that but in some broad
sense talking about a whole bunch of
atoms and molecules as a fluid is a
low-energy approximate effective field
theory because it's a fluid is a field a
fluid has all these different things at
every point in space it interacts with
itself locally etc etc so the
interesting part of that the reason why
I bring it up is because not only are
the equations governing what the gas is
doing different in the language of
particles versus the language of a fluid
the stuff is different it's a fluid it's
not a set of individual particles so
what's that what that saying is the
effective field theory need not describe
the same fields as whatever is going on
underneath and we see this in particle
physics all the time so we haven't gone
into the details about quarks and gluons
and QCD but you know you have you know
protons okay and you know that a proton
can be thought of here's a big proton as
a combination of three quarks there's an
up quark another up quark and a down
quark and they're interacting through
gluons the gluons are doing different
things gluons can direct with each other
we'll get to this we'll talk about it
eventually and the gluons interact in
different ways there's complicated
Fineman diagrams because you know gluons
are complicated lots of things going on
okay so the way to think about this is
is in the language of effective field
theories there is a scale
the QCD scale which is about 0.3 GeV
where the mass of the proton is about 1
GeV a GeV remember is a billion electron
volts the mass the proton is about 1 GeV
so the point is the QCD scale is the
scale at which the strong interactions
become strong just like electromagnetism
there's a coupling constant for the
strong interactions it changes with
energy scale just like the coupling
constant for electromagnetism does but
unlike electromagnetism where the closer
you get to the electron the stronger the
fine-structure constant seems the
charged electron is so the higher energy
the stronger the interaction is QCD
works the other way around at high
energies the interactions are weak at
low energies they're strong and the QCD
scale is the scale at which energies
become so strong that the effective
fine-structure constant becomes greater
than 1
remember when we did all that fireman
diagram stuff we said we had
perturbation theory it only makes sense
because more complicated diagrams have
more factors of alpha they get smaller
and smaller as you multiply them
together if the effective alpha you have
like you do in the strong interactions
is 1 or greater then this idea of doing
perturbation theory and adding up a
bunch of Lyman diagrams and just doesn't
work anymore you're not going to get a
sensible answer it's just not the right
technique the field theory still works
but the Fineman diagram approach to
solving problems in it doesn't work
anymore so what do you do what you do is
you say that above the QCD scale if
you're looking energies above that scale
you can talk the language of quarks and
gluons the quarks are the matter
particles they are held together by the
force particles gluons that are the
strong interaction version of photons
but below the QCD scale energies lower
than this ok roughly speaking mass of
the proton if we or ignore factors of
1/3 you can't talk that language anymore
but what you can do is talk the language
of protons and neutrons and pi ons and
all the other strongly interact
ding particles so those fields become
the important fundamental ingredients of
that effective field theory so there's
an effective field theory of strongly
interacting particles protons neutrons
ponds etc below the QCD scale and
there's a field theory of quarks and
gluons above the QCT scale now it so
happens that the theory of quarks and
gluons QCD quantum chromodynamics is one
of the rare quantum field theories that
we think could be extended infinitely
far infinitely far in energy in other
words if it weren't for gravity it
weren't for electromagnetism and all
those annoying forces of nature
if the world were just quantum
chromodynamics we would have the full
theory we'd have the ultraviolet
complete theory of nature you can
actually do calculations to arbitrarily
high energies in QCD which you can't do
in QED or quantum gravity etc but
putting that aside the point is at
different energies with different
cut-offs not only do you have different
values of coupling constants you have a
different set of fields entirely that's
what I mean by the ontology here the set
of fields that are making up your theory
so effective field theory is powerful
and flexible enough to let you say that
if I'm at high energies like fields of
my theory or quarks and gluons at lower
energies the fields of my theory are
protons and neutrons and pi ons etc so
that's what effective field that's
another thing that effective field
theories allow you to do ok last
question I have here which is kind of
related the effective field theory of
general relativity or gravity the
specific question that they really
caught my eye was relativity I spelled
it right look at that
the specific question was can you
actually reconstruct the successful
empirical behavior such as the
gravitational redshift just from an
effective field theory of gravity so
gravitational redshift is if you here's
the earth here's the ground and you
built a tower and at the top of the
tower you have an experimenter so here's
a tower and what you're gonna do is
you're gonna
a flashlight so you have some
flashlights or some laser tuned some
very very specific frequency okay so
it's only giving off a particular
frequency of light so you shine a photon
up there and the point is that if it
moves against the gravitational field if
it's climbing out of the gravitational
field the frequency that is observed by
the observer at high altitude is a lower
frequency a longer wavelength redshifted
okay this is one of the first
predictions of general relativity that
einstein himself made it was not
actually measured until decades later
the pound replica experiment is a famous
example and these days we've measured it
in a variety of contexts now what you
will find if you read general relativity
books such as the one that I wrote
spacetime in geometry what you will find
is that this existence of the
gravitational redshift is used as an
argument in favor of thinking of gravity
as a manifestation of the curvature of
space-time okay so you might say well
alright there's this experiment I did it
I made a prediction but I didn't see any
words in there about geometry or metrics
or curvature or anything like that what
does that have to do with anything but
there's an argument because basically
what you can draw some triangles and
some rectangles and and make an argument
with rocket ships that you know we're
accelerating and say the only way that I
could possibly explain what's going on
here is to change the geometry of
space-time itself okay I'm not gonna
rehearse that argument we haven't talked
about gravity yet but it exists so that
seems naively to be in conflict with the
claim that you can just think of gravity
as a field theory in some background
flat space-time so the effective field
theory of general relativity says
gravity the gravitational field what
would I say gravity equals flat
space-time plus an appropriate
gravitational field
and it works out that the gravitational
field is a tensor it's basically a
metric tensor it's a the technical terms
which we'll get to later or it is a
symmetric to index tensor field okay it
is not just the simple laplace
gravitational potential it's more
complicated than that but it serves the
same purpose as the plazas gravitational
potential field okay so this is the EFT
perspective and the question is how do
you reconcile these two claims one claim
is the empirical existence of
gravitational redshift is evidence that
we should think of gravity as the
curvature of space-time the second claim
is in the effective field theory
language we don't need to have curved
space-time we can have flat space-time
and on top of it we can have a
gravitational field the answer is you
know it's a little bit subtle and many
of you are not you know already in
immersed in these issues might not care
or see why we should care but the point
is yes they're perfectly compatible with
each other because of the specific
properties that this gravitational field
has so the claim that I want to make so
forget about the details I try to get
into a detail but the take-home message
is as long as you are in the weak field
regime as long as you were in the regime
of gravity where curvature of space-time
is not too strong so that means you're
nowhere near a black hole your knowing
you're the big bang maybe not even near
a neutron star but otherwise if you're
talking about the earth the Sun
gravitational waves all these other
things that we observe in our local
neighborhood the gravity is very very
weak it's a weak force and in that
regime I want to claim the effective
field theory of general relativity as a
quantum field theory works totally well
you just have to stay away from the
cutoff where gravity becomes strong okay
how do you reconcile that well it's
because of the actual properties of this
gravitational field and I tried to think
about you know how I could explain this
in equations given what we already know
and it's hard to do so I'm not going to
do it but I'm going to try to just say
it in words the point is that gravity is
special
cause gravity is a source of gravity
this is something that would not have
been true for Newton but is true in
general relativity so in the language of
the effective field theory you know in
the language of general relativity
itself the way Einstein wrote it down
you know Einstein wrote this complicated
nonlinear set of equations for the
gravitational field and there's no sense
in those equations that it looks like
gravity is the source of gravity but
here we're doing something different
we're starting with flat space-time and
we're imagining that on top of that
there is a gravitational field just like
all those other fields that we drew
right the gravitational field and in
this language that gravitational field
that is just a small ripple because
we're in the weak field it interacts not
only with every other field but it also
interacts with itself so those are two
separate statements and they're both
very very important where the
gravitational field interacts with
everything and it interacts universally
with everything so it interacts in the
same way with electrons and positrons
and protons and neutrons the strength of
the interaction is proportional to the
mass or the energy of the thing being
interacted with but the net effect is
exactly the same so this goes back to
Galileo Galileo dropping two different
objects with different masses off the
Leaning Tower of Pisa he probably never
did that but he did equivalent
experiments Galileo was the one who
showed that gravity has this universal
aspect things fault the same rate in a
gravitational field and Einstein did
thought experiments with elevators and
so forth to show the same thing in this
language that fact that gravity is
universal that has the same effect on
everything including photons that will
gravitationally redshift implies that
there's a very very specific way that
you need to construct the effective
field theory for gravity there's a very
very specific way that the gravitational
field can couple can interact with all
the other fields including itself so you
don't have a lot of freedom you're
incredibly tight
be constrained by things like the
redshift gravitational redshift
experiment the equivalence principle
different objects follow different rates
all that stuff and so it turns out and
this is the miracle when you say well I
have a field with certain properties it
kind of looks like gravity and I insist
that it couples to everything including
itself in a way such that everything is
universal then that fixes not just the
simple interaction you write down but
the entire infinite set of interactions
in your effective field theory okay up
to some cutoff of course you always have
to cut off but there's no arbitrariness
there is a way that everything has to
couple together and so if the
gravitational field is usually written
as H of X for reasons which we don't be
going to right now and there's a
Lagrangian that involves H of X
multiplying the electron field and the
photon field and everything else and
this rule of universal coupling
specifies all the different ways that H
can appear in that Lagrangian and it
turns out this was work done by people
like Stephen Weinberg and Richard
Fineman they're less famous work but
they did this Stan Lee desert also made
arguments to this effect that whole
different infinite set of interactions
between the gravitational effect of
field theory field and everything else
can be summarized uniquely into
Einstein's equations for gravity the
whole nine linear nonlinear mess that
even gives you black holes in the Big
Bang and all that stuff so because
gravity is so highly constrained this
gravitational field that you would think
of as the effective thing that is
propagating on flat space-time has to
interact in a very very specific way
such that it is equivalent to saying
that the geometry of space-time itself
is being affected so these are two
different languages to say the same
thing
Einstein would say what's going on is
that space-time has a geometry
everything just feels that geometry and
reacts to it the effective field
theorist says there's a gravitational
field that has an interaction Lagrangian
that has coupling constants that work in
certain ways it turns out they are exam
exactly the same thing in different
languages now Einsteins language is a
little bit more general because it
actually applies to black holes and
things like this you can work to apply
this kind of language to black holes in
some sense but Einstein is more flexible
so this is again an effective field
theory it has a certain domain of
applicability but it reproduces all of
the geometric predictions of Einstein
all the equivalence principle stuff all
the arguments that you should think of
gravity is the curvature of space-time
do have analogs in this way of thinking
as gravity is not the curvature of
space-time but it's because it secretly
is I guess that's what I'm trying to get
at even though the language is not
gravity's the curvature of space-time
it's a really really complicated and
awkward looking way of summarizing the
fact the gravity is actually the
curvature of space-time so this is yet
another testament to the power of
effective field theories there there are
things that we don't know things that we
don't know like gravity near the Planck
scale or near high curvature regimes
that you that do not prevent you from
using effective field theories at low
energies it's an incredibly powerful
tool for thinking about the world and
until we do have the theory of
everything it's the best we got